Okay, this is Dr. Chemical Cutters. Welcome to another holistic health hour.
This is episode 12. We've got a bunch of questions that came in.
So we are going to jump to those questions. Okay, um, first question was, what is the CA 125
blood test? So a CA 125 blood test is a tumor marker test. I have a whole blog on
tumor marker tests and what they mean. Um, tumor marker tests were developed
decades ago and it was in the hopes that that was going to be a great marker for
monetary to person's cancer, either the progression in a good way or a bad way and through
the treatment plan. Um, they are tests that are measuring different proteins, so they're normally
found in person's body, but they can be expressed at a greater amount if a person has cancer.
And if the cancer is growing and getting worse, those tumor marker proteins can go up. Now there are
number of these tumor markers that have been discovered. Now the truth is that they're not
super accurate as far as using them as objective data to see whether the person is getting better
or getting worse. And if the person is undergoing chemotherapy, it can make them even
less accurate because if a person's tumor is breaking up and dying quickly, it can
spill out a lot more of these proteins and a person's tumor markers can actually be elevated
and give them a false sense that they're getting worse when they're actually getting better. So
a lot of oncologists ceased using tumor marker tests because of that because they'd have to explain
to the patient, um, that it's not a very accurate test. Well, then why are you running it? When I'm doing
chemo, when they're explaining, well, when you're doing chemo, then these aren't really accurate tests.
It just gets very confusing. So they've kind of fallen out of use. But for a person who is
wanting to monitor their cancer in a less invasive way because they don't want to go and get
another CT scanner. They don't want to go and get another PET scanner. They don't want to do those
quite so often because that involves radiation or an MRI. They involve
gadolidium or, you know, something that can be potentially dangerous to the person's body.
We could do tumor marker blood tests so you could get those run. Now the pros and cons of them are
they can bounce around a little bit. It's not a perfect objective data. But the truth is
if you've heard me talk about any objective data, no objective data is perfect. Even a gold standard
PET scan isn't perfect. A gold standard CT scan can be picking up swelling around a cancer that
is not actually growth. It's actually in a inflammatory process that the cancer has died.
So you have to take any objective test, any test that you got to weigh it with other tests that
you're doing and subject of findings to really go whether the person is getting better or getting
worse or the progression of care. So there's pros and cons to it. But what are the pros
of doing tumor marker tests? Is the fact that it isn't invasive? So the non-invasiveness of doing
tumor marker tests can be super beneficial for a person who doesn't want to go and do a PET scan
or a CT scan or something like that. Now the other problem with them is that some people
will have a cancer that doesn't show tumor markers. So the thing to do is to run the test
relatively soon in your care plan so you know that where your baseline is. So in our Rupa
lab store we have a male tumor marker panel and a female tumor marker panel that tests for I think
five or six tumor marker labs and then it's relatively inexpensive. I think there are only about
90 bucks or something like that to run a tumor marker panel. But at least you could know that you have
kind of a baseline of whether you even show tumor markers or not and that gives you an idea whether
it's going to be a good objective test for you to continue to run it or a regular base to see how
you're doing. But that's CA 125 is just one of those tumor marker tests that you can
that you could look at. So you can submit more questions on the chat history reminder of that.
Next question that came in was by 71 year old husband just just received lab results
back showing that his April lipo protein B is 159 the rate normal rate is 55 to 140
and I will state that that's the lab range. And whenever you're looking at any tests understand that
there is a there's a lab range and then there's a functional range that we look at. So different labs
when you run different tests are going to have their own range of normals. They're high at low
range. Now from a functional perspective our ranges are typically tighter than that. So
so this person's April lipo protein B which is often abbreviated April B is 159 normal
lab range is 55 to 140 so that's elevated it is lipo protein A is 90 and the normal lab range is
2253 so that's elevated. This person states that the question is hard to find.
Although he has had high blood pressure at high cholesterol since childhood
he's not overweight. Should he be concerned about these high latest test numbers? Thank you
Dr. Keller. So the answer is well you don't want to necessarily be scared whatever you do any lab
tests. You don't want to make that bring fear to your heart because you know fear and anxiety
what does that do is stimulates your sympathetic nervous system and that can make make anything worse.
But you do a test to look objectively at things at data to decide whether you need to do something
and I would say yes this should spark you to do something. April lipo protein B in your body
actually goes on to form what are called the LDLs very low density lipo proteins they combine
with triglycerides and then the circulator out your body and then the dump off a triglyceride
it up 40, 40 LDLs so these are the these are the bad cholesterol portions of cholesterol. Now
you have that your husband obviously ran a good lab for the breakdown of cholesterol and fats
because most labs that you're going to run just a standard lab you're going to run total cholesterol
HDL and LDL and that's probably it. So if you're going to do more of a cardiac profile then you're
going to break it down into these smaller proteins or these smaller fats and even a better lab will
even break it down to oxidized LDLs and oxidized different fats which give us an idea of risk of
cardiovascular disease. So this gives us an idea of risk of cardiovascular disease. So
if this was my lab and this was my you remember my care team we would definitely want to
investigate deeper. So whatever you have these elevated fats that are coming from the liver
you want to make sure that you're you're protecting this person as best as you can from a natural
perspective so that they don't have damage to their arterials. This is what can lead to placky.
This is what can lead to damage the the endothelial cells. Those are the cells that line the vessels
and you get inflammation of the endothelial lighting and that can block the arteries and it can block
the flow to your heart and when you have terminal vessels to the heart you're going to have
loss of oxygen and that's what a cardiovascular event is cause from. So you want to prevent that
and the reason why you would do this test is to see where you're at. So yes I would definitely even
if the person is not this is a perfect example. Some people think it's oh well if the person is more
aware of the obese they're going to have a higher risk. We've taken blood work from people that are
in that category and all these numbers are normal. So the risk involves some familial traits like
you said he's had high cholesterol for his whole life and there can be a familial hypercholesterolemia
issue and it does presuppose people to a greater risk of cardiovascular events because of that. So
personally I would not take this lightly. I would do make some moves from a nutritional standpoint
to help deal with that. With cardiovascular studies I think I have more blogs on this
than I created a number of years ago. I would also look at the H. Pylori blog on our website as well
because H. Pylori is a major player that is which cause cardiovascular events because it is a
major player that causes endothelial inflammation. So when H. Pylori which is a bacteria that
really starts off in the gut is the number one cause of stomach and duodenal ulcers. It is
it can go systemic. It can cause very commonly it's one of the top five causes of cardiovascular
disease, endothelial disease. It gets underneath the endothelial layer causes damage to the
bio cardio layer layers, damages to the muscle causes this chronic inflammatory state because of
it's it's it's an effective organism it's grabbed negative bacteria. So you want to make sure
you investigate for that and basically treat for that. That's why I've said over and over again
that burberry is probably one of my favorite supplements because burberry is one of your best killers
H. Pylori and everybody you know has issues with H. Pylori at some point in life and that could be a problem.
So yes I would investigate deeper I would it be scared this might if you've never had this test before
and that's what's good to get labs on a regular basis because if you did have this test before
your numbers were within normal limits then you want to you know be quicker to make some
decisions on care and move forward. If you've had these tests before and they've always been high
still it's not a reason to just say well that's just my normal you do want to deal with it.
And the cancer is a big thing that we deal with at our clinic cardiovascular disease is still
the number will cause a death of it at its dates and done it's because when when people have these
numbers typically when they go to a cardiologist they're just given drugs and while drugs can bring
the lab values closer to normal they're not really dealing with the underlining cause
you know you don't deal with the other like cause you still have the same degree of
possible risk of mortality and at least morbidity from the disorder so you want to dig in to
cause and treat the causes best you possibly get even if you're going to still use medication.
Okay next question I'd like to get a rife machine I found your recommendation from three years ago
here in the list of what rife machine do we recommend it must have been a video or a webpage
that we talked about are these still the factors to consider and the models you'd recommend things
so I did not have time to I don't know really have time to research any of these questions
you guys said in so I'm assuming that page talks about I think I made a video a number of years ago
about some some key points that I look at I'm looking at the quality and effectiveness of a rife
machine that I might have them in a different order here but the first has to be a light frequency so
rife is frequency medicine rife is using frequencies to try to help your body heal and
one of my qualifications in a rife machine because there's a lot of rife machines out there
you know rife is just the name of royal raven rife so anybody could say they have a rife
machine and it could be a whatever right so there's a lot of rife machines out there that are
frequency generators but they're using electrical frequency or they're using sound frequency
well to me that's not what I at least would define a rife machine rife machine is using light
frequency that's what's going to be right light is different than sound is different than electrical
though they all have their benefits electrical frequency could be great for muscular skeletal issues
sound frequency can be good for joint issues and fluid issues but light frequency light is a different
waveform light is a photon carried on the waveform and it has different properties and it affects
the cellular structure differently and royal rife found that using light frequency especially with
dealing with cancer dealing with organisms that you're trying to kill like pathogens that was the
best thing to use it in my experience usually rife since the late nineties now going on 25 years
I've used just about everyone out there so first of all qualify it in my definition of a rife
machine it has to use light frequency and then secondly it has to have enough amperage that's what's
pushing the frequencies out in order for it to penetrate your body so if you're using light frequency
but it doesn't have enough power the machine doesn't have enough power for the frequencies to penetrate
your body what's it's useless it's not doing anything and then third it has to be programmable
so if it comes with a set of frequencies for you know that are really simplistic and you can't
program it for what that patient needs it's use is going to be is going to be you know minor because
you're dealing with somebody that has okay let's just use hpylori for example it's a
gram negative bacteria if you don't have a hpylori you know different frequencies there's there's
there's dozens of frequencies that have been found to help kill hpylori but if your rife machine
only has one frequency for bacteria or something that most likely it's not going to be dealing with
you know the right frequency to kill hpylori you could run it tell your eyes to her green but
you're not going to it's not going to effectively do anything for you so it has to be programmable
so that you can program it specifically for your needs that you could add frequencies that are
committed to greater knowledge through practitioners and you could add more things otherwise
you know it's not working and then lastly it has to be a user friendly so if it's not really easy
to use just like any piece of exercise equipment you're not going to use it so I'd hate to have
somebody buy a rife machine it might be really powerful it may be really good it might even be
programmable but it's really kind of complicated to turn on and because of that they don't use it
well you know use something even if it's the greatest thing in the world it's not going to work
so we have settled on the true rife I do think the gb4000 fits those criteria as well accept that
last one that's not as easy to use it's definitely not as easy to use and it's much more difficult
to program so that third one is an issue but it is very powerful and I like it actually have one
behind me but I have a true rife right front of you here too so the true rife is the one that we use
because of those criteria if another one comes in the market that's I think better than
I'll switch to that but right now yes answer your question those models I recommend
so we if people call us and want to buy a rife machine for us they're getting a true rife
so that as far as I'd like to buy a rife machine you can't just buy one right off our store
they don't recommend that and I might not sell it to you so if it will that's mean what do you do that
well I mean what I mean is if you're going to buy a rife machine for I want to work best for you
so I got to get to know you we need to do a case review and know what your needs are
for me to program it for your needs so set up a case review is what you want to do
do you have any bird's fly in one of those window bird feeders about three feet away from me
and how much chicken he's in there do you have any herb or supplement recommendations for
braid mid-geoma so mid-geoma is a tumor a benign tumor in the mid-gees of the braid so the
mid-gees of your braid are the duramata and the piumata that encase your braid and protect your
braid and those are the what are called the mid-gees from an anatomical perspective now you can
get a tumor that's embedded in those mid-gees and that's what's called a mid-geoma so a mid-geoma is
a benign tumor that's in the mid-gees can be anywhere that's encompassing in those mid-gees that are
protecting the braid they're not considered deadly but they can be they can cause a lot of
morbidity because you know as they as any space occupied lesion in the skull it can compress as it
gets larger it can compress and and damage duronal flow in the cortex and that's what causes problems
so there's other benign brain tumors typically fall and most common would be what's called
a glioma that are considered benign but now they're staged differently they just actually change
a staging of those a few years ago to what's called a grading system because the higher the
grade the greater chance it has to become a a cancerous tumor where it is malignant and
depending on how fast it's growing it yeah optimize more space causes more inflammation it causes more
damage and the person's gonna have damage and compromise depending on where fat tumor is so mid-geoma
same thing you're gonna have more compromise depending on where that tumor is what are some herbs or
supplements for that well the biggest thing that you want to be concerned with with a glioma or
mid-geoma is decreasing inflammation so decreasing inflammation is is really the key there's
across the board and this really goes for anything that's going out of the braid is decreasing
inflammation because again you have a minimal amount of space and it's taken up all by your brain
you don't have extra space you don't have a lot of extra space in your skull so when you have a tumor
growing in there it's going to impede a brain tissue like I've said so decreasing inflammation has
got to be your key so what is the best what are the best things to do to decrease inflammation
well I could run it off a lot of supplements but they all fitted to this group called flavonoids or
bio flavonoids so flavonoid type supplements are your your curcumin your vasuelia your white willow bark
your green t-extract your resveratrol those are your flavonoids of course it is a whole bunch of them
so those are anti-inflammatory nutrients that can that can help decrease inflammation of the
brain but doing that alone I think is a mistake you've got to look at part two is you've got to look
at what increases inflammation in the brain so what are things that could increase inflammation
in the brain because I mean you could take a zillion you know you could take ten grams of
curcumin you know it wouldn't be recommended but yeah I would say and you could take a ton of
these flavonoids and anti-inflammatories but if you have some source of that's that's fueling the
inflammatory process it behooves us to try to decrease the source of inflammation and you
were going to get better results by taking anti-inflammatories make sense right so
yes taking flavonoids is key but you have to investigate what are some things that are
causes of brain inflammation so I do have a video if you look up on our log in and I gonna a lot of
these questions are gonna point you back to our blog because I've made videos on a lot of this stuff
already so there's a video I think it's called brain inflammation or it's neural inflammation
the talks about brain inflammation and microglio primate though you could equate the
the the correction of that the the remedy for that to this to gliomas and to meningiomas as well
so dealing with some causes that increase inflammation around a meningioma or glioma or
or my prime microglial cells are going to be the same first would be some standard things that this
person a person with a meningioma or any of these things that I discussed has to cut out immediately
would be alcohol there's just there's just too many studies that show that that is true now understand
a lot of this data on brain inflammation has surfaced in the last 10 years I don't know if you remember
a number of years ago there was these huge lawsuits with the national football league because
there was some retired football players that had major brain issues and and up with suicidal
events and different things like that that really brought to light issues that happened because of
post-concussive syndrome so millions of dollars were dumped into the research pool for post-concussive
on issues in and what what concussions due to the brain which are caused damage to the brain inflammation
not unlike what happens with an Alzheimer's patient not unlike what happens with multiple sclerosis
patient or anybody that has antibodies to neural tissue and like I mentioned microglial primate
so watch that video it's about a half hour video of course so through that in in detail but some
general things that are always going to cause inflammation of the brain even when you don't have
issues with the brain you're going to have an increase inflammation of the brain when you consume
alcohol of any kind alcohol does increase inflammation of the brain if you already have insult to the
brain via in a geomore gliomore microglial primate or antibodies to neural tissue it's going to make
that worse and so that's got to be something that the person cuts out of their life. Secondly is
different foods that cause inflammation of the brain and just across the just right off the bat even
if you don't have antibodies to these two food groups you have to really at least limit them
and that is gluten and dairy it's the you have gluteumorphine receptors in the gut that fire into the
brain you have caseumorphine receptors in the gut that fire to the brain those are the proteins of
gluten and dairy it would be wise to get a test done which would test for all the peptides of gluten
or glee added the glee added peptides which are the little parts of the whole protein itself
and across the reactants of glee added and kc so getting that test done that's a Syrex lab
that's the name of the lab Syrex array the rex and array four and you can find that in our lab
store in any of our courses so understand you know if you guys are listening to this and you
not you know you've never looked at our website or never looked at our courses you're missing out
and I'm talking really fast here I understand but go to our blogs I have a lot of this information
of the blogs like I said and join one of our join our course our autoimmune course or product disease
and autoimmune course probably the best course we got join that course I go into great detail on all
this stuff that we're talking about and through the courses you could order labs at our cost we
don't mark them up one penny why don't make a penny off of any of our labs so but then you can find
out some data and that can be helpful so like I said you use anti-inflammatory flavonoids for
a midagual or back to our question you would find out what is other causes of inflammation
and you would treat that so you get rid of alcohol you get rid of you know at least cut down
glue to the dairy run a test if you have antibodies if you have any antibody study those then you
have to cut them out completely run a food antibody test for other foods and clean up that clean up your
gut can greatly decrease the inflammation of your brain testing for pesticides testing for
antibodies to other pathogens because other pathogens so you dig down to if you ever asked your
neurologist what causes but in geoboes they'd say well it's just tough luck buddy but the truth is is
that there's a cause to everything so the the underlining caused to a glioma or an angioma
or cancer or multiple sclerosis or there are underlining causes often they're from pathogens
often they're from chemical toxins so just cleaning up the rest of your body can be really really helpful
and there's other labs that you could run to dig to those causes as well so
well that was a long answer to that I apologize but hopefully that will help question on
methylene blue do you recommend it and it's use orally or otherwise thank you very much god bless you
they're so polite I know that there's other doctors out there that really push some different
products like methylene blue is pushed by Dr. Bacolo really big honestly I'm not a fan
and I'll tell you why because methylene blue is that is a methyl donor so okay so to understand that
is that we pick up methyl groups a methyl group in chemistry is a carbon with three hydrogens attached
to it and it's an ion it attaches to things quite easily and it is necessary in our body we need methyl
groups we we make methyl groups through pathway through what's called our folate pathway and then
through the methionine pathway these are two metabolic pathways in our body these are two pathways
that we assess when we do a full genetic workup on somebody well a lot of doctors that do a genetic
workup on somebody have a I don't know how to say this nice but they don't have a like a
real deep understanding of what they're doing with their they think that they're treating gene defects
so a real common thing that effect there's there's even Facebook groups that talk about
the defect in a specific gene family called an MTHFR gene so and there's been like
there's people that feel like they're cursed because they have an MTHFR gene defect like
like there's somehow defective people and they have all sorts of problems with everything in life now
this is just so untrue so the treatment for this is they get on excess methyl groups they
typically jump they get on or their practitioner puts them on methyl cobalamine which is a methyl
type of B12 and they put them on methyl folate which is methyl tetrahedral folate which those things
aren't bad those things are found in nature if you eat a lot of green leafy vegetables you're
getting a natural form of folate but the problem is is that we we're taking a bioptic view of that
and we're not looking at all the genetics if you kind of if you just start taking a whole bunch of
excess methyl groups and and understand that you know the question of taking methylene blue that's
going to be that's adding a whole bunch more excess methyl groups you could you'll also push
another pathway called your bioptorin pathway and if you have defects on that pathway especially the
serotonin genes you're going to push out excess serotonin and that's not going to be good you're
going to end up having issues from that so I would just be careful jumping on a supplement
bandwagon without really taking a good assessment of your whole body now somebody that doesn't have any
defects or very few defects in their bioptorin pathway would probably be able to get on you know
fairly high dose of methylfolate methylcapolamine and even methylene blue would not have any issues
but I've seen time and time again where people will call me and have a case review and they're like I had
a doctor said I had a MTHFRG defect put me on methylfolate this is before methylene blue is big
and I just got these issues now anger and I just can't control it well this you look at
their full genetic profile they got defects in their bioptorin pathway they're just
spilling out too much serotonin and they can have a lot of aggression issues and
just emotional imbalances because those are neurotransmitters and you you want to look at the
whole big picture it's just kind of like treating somebody with just a little snippet of objective data
you want to try to get as much objective data and subjective data before you put together a
treatment protocol that can alter things and maybe over correct if you defense the right terminology
and so I'd be careful about that so no personally I don't use methylene blue and I don't recommend it
for people and it partly has to do it you know we see a lot of people with a cancer diagnosis so you
don't want excess methyl groups what you have a cancer diagnosis especially because one of the
things that methyl groups do is they silence genes and we don't want to have any excess silence
seed of tumor suppressor genes because that is your key defensive strategy from
from an intracellular function for you to be able to kill cancer cells and when you have
silenced tumor suppressor genes you're you're hindering your body's ability to cause apoptosis to
a growing cancer mass so I'm not a big fan of excess methyl groups especially with cancer patients
the only time I'll recommend methyl groups is you look at a person's you get more data right so I don't
recommend methyl groups just based upon a person's genes you don't treat gene defects but it's
beneficial to you know you do want to give methyl groups to a person who has elevated
homocysteine so that's that's not going to be followed through genetics that's going to be followed
through a complete metabolic panel with a person that's elevated homocysteine you want to add methyl
groups and it might only be temporarily until you bring that down and um support that pathway
question came into the chat what's the best protocol for Epstein bar virus
so Epstein bar virus is a one of those chronic viruses that are very difficult to ultimately kill
um the one of the things that I'd caution you about is is is or question you about is how do you know
if you have it um there's a lot of tests out there that are IGG tests for viruses and I can tell you
how many people I do a case review with and they send me their labs and and they was they had
Epstein bar IGG test that was positive that does not mean you have Epstein bar that means you were
exposed to Epstein bar at one time matter fact I can show you a study that 80% of the human population
will show positive IGG antibodies for Epstein bar we've all been exposed to it if it settles as a
chronic infection in your body then it would be it would show differently and if it's currently
causing you issues it would show positive as an IGM antibody so you want to make sure you're not
treating ghosts um you see that a lot in the live community where people will be treating chronic
Lyme and they're constantly trying to kill the chronic Lyme um but they don't they don't have any
merelia or co-infections anymore they're they're not present anymore it was what that did did to
their body when it was present that is causing their symptoms an Epstein bar can be the same thing
so a person had a really bad Epstein bar infection 20 years ago and it lit up antibodies to
self-tissue so now you are really dealing with an autoimmune disease not a current infection of
Epstein bar or a current infection of merelia burgodorphine you're dealing with the autoimmune
component in the damage to the tissue so further investigation is really important if the person does
have IGM antibodies to Epstein bar pretend so I'm not trying to so the question if you truly do have
a current Epstein bar infection it's a virus and it's difficult to kill whether a virus is even
killable is even questionable um this this is one thing that I like the the rife machine for because
it could really help people with really chronic true infections a chronic um uh compromised immune
systems and um and cancers and uh other chronic pathogens um that's the best use of a rife machine
supporting um the immune system is really key but I again you really have to be careful because
um there's there people that are constantly adding kill protocols from a supplement standpoint
so they hear about a new it can't claw protocol or something so they're doing immune stimulating
supplements to kill this perceived infection that would use that carefully but try to insult anybody
but they really are sick so they think it's the MC bar or it's the Lyme disease it's flared it's ugly
head again so they take some more immune stimulating things because it makes sense if I have a
current infection I want to kill that current infection so I'm going to take a bunch of immune
stimulants to kill it but if truly their symptoms are due to an autoimmune disease meaning they have
antibodies to self tissue and destruction further destruction because of multiple triggers that are
triggering destruction um that self tissue is causing that person's increase in symptoms and they
are perceive it as uh a current infection and they add immune stimulants they're actually making their
problem much much worse um because if you have a current autoimmune flare and you are
destroying self tissue you're doing so through the immune system it's the immune systems destruction
of self tissue and if you stimulate the immune system at this point in time you're going to make
the you're fueling the immune systems ability to kill yourself um I have I go into this
ad nausea in the autoimmune course and it's cheap to enjoy that course and learn more about that
if you know you don't have self antibodies meaning you don't have you've done like a CyRx5 and 7 and 10
and you've done these labs and you know I don't have any self antibodies we don't do not have
an autoimmune disease in any of the three phases of an autoimmune disease
then it's certainly safe to you know um to treat with immune stimulating nutrition
and there's a lot of different varieties of immune stimulated nutrition for different viruses
um but if um and especially if you couple that with an IgM test knowing that you have a current
infection the current exposure and you need to stimulate your immune system to balance that
then you're safe to use immune stimulants like the straggolus and you know we'd be invited to see
things without any damage to self tissue because you don't have any self antibodies but I would do
those tests first and rule those out because you can make yourself worse there's a lot of people in the
live community that you know they can't get out of that self-destruction and they've had you know
their disease for 10 years and they're mistreated it they're mistreated as an active infection
when it's not an active infection anymore it's an autoimmune disorder and they've never run
those tests that how we could know so you got to run those labs to no at least rule that out
there's a lot of a lot of issues that could cause dysfunction and and it'll help and so you've got to
get a you know as big of objective pictures you possibly can to rule out uh and rule in what's
what's right and wrong what's your what you need to do uh take a couple more questions here
not sure if this question went through if somebody has very dense breast and
cancer is in the breast is a diagnostic mammogram dangerous because of the compression
would it be better to wait till I get an appointment for molecular imaging at male clinic if I have had
a thermography appointment as well thanks um well from a medical standpoint they will you know
that's going to be just their protocol so if you go into standard of care treatment for uh you know
you know say you have a suspected lump in the breast it's going to be mammogram um ultrasound
and biopsy I mean you know with very little sway to any of those things
now we've had lots of people that said I don't want to do a mammogram I you know I don't
I think there's dangers to that it's radiation I just want to do an ultrasound and I'm willing to do
a biopsy but I did you know so you can push back in the defense on your doctor and your relationship
with that doctor how much leeway you're going to have with that you may have to find somebody that
will work with you so but they're that that's what's called standards of care so in the practice
of medicine if they don't follow standards of care they risk getting lawsuits um so they're going
to all follow standards of care and gone other days are a mark as well be trying to care for the patient
individually everybody's just trying to cover their behind and everybody you know the doctors don't rule
anymore used to be that one older doctor would run be running the hospital because he was really
good at administration and the rest of the doctors you know made clinical decisions based upon their
education that's that just isn't there anymore doctors are just technicians they're following
right what's on the computer screen telling them what to do and if they don't do that they get
docked and I would hate to be a medical doctor in the in the standards of care you can't think
anymore they just taken that completely off the table so um yeah so you're going to have to you
know make the best decision what's best for you um try to find a doctor that will work with you
uh best protocol for Candida and yeast overgrowth feeling through all these episodes we're going to
get questions like this and these are very honest questions what's the best protocol um the truth is
is that there isn't I don't I don't I don't know how to say this really nicely but I know we just
we are so conditioned through the medical system that here's my I've gotten to this diagnosis um
however I've gotten to this diagnosis give me the medication to a go away um that's not really in my
mind the proper way to take care of somebody the proper way to take care of somebody is okay maybe
we have this diagnosis but let's ask a question why why is it there is it because you have a deficiency
of this Candida supplement that's why you have Candida you know though that might really help
we're not going to ultimately help the patient unless we dig to why what's the is there in balance
in the in the um microbiota because of what let's figure that out and if we can figure that out
and treat that maybe we don't even have to seek that other supplement right or that drug or whatever
um so it's not is you know I wish I could you know why are you going to be mad at me I ask you the
questions of just give me a supplement they're just give me a medication or give me a solution um
that's not the right way to take care of somebody um in my book sure there there's a ton of
kid every supplement company that we use has a Candida protocol um but then aren't we being just
like the practice of medicine who is still different than than um then uh you know having a
Birk manual that a medical doctor follows and he's he or she or just a technician and they come to
this diagnosis because then we did this lab and here's the diagnosis here's the drug that we give
by come back at three months and we'll see how you're doing and see if we've altered the lab value
maybe you will but did you did you help the person you know in any in any real way did you really
correct the reason why um and this is you know we could do the same thing in natural realms too
right I don't like doing that so um you know I don't really have a good answer for that I apologize
my answer would be we need to dig into dig deeper just figure out the reasons why uh
question it I have a lump on my lower leg doctor said he didn't think it was anything
and two ultrasounds have a CT scan tomorrow doctor said he may have it removed worried about
that iodide die is that dangerous okay so a lot of lumps you know it's really hard to answer this
without actually seeing and looking at that but a lot of lumps are superficial lumps on your surface
on your skin you know most common thing would be a lipoma um but almost any doctor that has any
experience can basically palpate that lump and tell with with a fair degree of certainty whether it's
a lipomo or not because it'll typically be movable you know feel like it's encapsulated and um um
um but there's nothing wrong with getting some imaging done so I think that's the right thing to do
is to get some imaging done I'm not sure what you're talking about with the iodide die
um a CT scan is going to have radiation and a CT scan with contrast um is you know you know you're
getting semi invasive there but still you want to rule that out you want to make sure there is
anything anything more serious um most surface lumps on adults are going to be bedaid um if it's a
child in a lump on their leg that's very scary you got different sarcomas you have different um
cancers that can be very serious on a younger person but typically on an older person is it's in
your thigh or something you get a lump it's both commonly a podaid tumor lipoba is one of the more
common ones um and lipomas can be surgically excised very easily um if you don't have multiple
lipomas um typically they don't come back I mean people people can get different people can have
you know different lipomas come back um but it's not that that lipoba is spreadied or anything like
a metastatic tumor or anything like that so um it's good that you're getting it checked out I wouldn't
be overly nervous about it it's but um um it's definitely good to get checked out and getting
lipoma removed typically it involves no danger whatsoever um it's very common occurrence
okay we're almost at our time oh we had some other questions that came in and remember you could
ask questions um on our website um in the box that's on the website no just it's just creating an app
and hold new website for the holistic health hours that's going to point people to this is the last
question that came in before it said I'm on a medication I don't know if I remember if I answered
this last week do I have to take the medication several hours away from using the right um so if a
person is using a knife machine is that going to interfere with the medication they're using
is what this person's asking the answer is no and the right does not interfere with any medication
any supplements does not interfere with anything else you're doing so it's using light frequencies
and there's no contact or indications of using the right while you're doing anything else um you can
even use other therapies while you're doing the right um you can use a right if you have a
electrical implanted device like a pacemaker there's no there's no contraindications to using a right
all right well thank you for being on today's episode we'll have this up as a recording
if you missed any part of it you want to go back or if you have a friend that you want to refer
to hear these questions um appreciate uh everybody participating and we'll see you next week bye